remember like how old were you first
time he got knocked out like actually
knocked out oh I was a little kid
how old I don't know 11 11 years old
yeah who was the guy oh he hit me with a
bat yeah
they don't know our world he knew in a
bat that's out thank you it's like
normal right
as a matter of fact the first time I got
hit we have something in common yeah I
got hit with a bat and they broke two of
my room yeah
with bats and people shoot at us at 11
years old Peter's success is getting hit
by bat I got hit by a club you remember
the club in the in the cars the clubs
you used to put to steering wheels I got
hit in the club
18 years old in Kentucky I'm like damn I
saw somebody get hit with that too split
this thing too I broke my nose I woke up
four o'clock in the morning is that is
that what happened that's one of the
ways I wanted to Broken my nose a few
times he's always still cause he had to
break that up was actually it was old
school way it's before we had uh the
current alarm stuff I'll never forget
the story when you guys did the
interview at the MGM inside the uh the
ring literally and you were talking
about one of the first times that Mike I
don't know if this was one of the first
but when you really knew that you had
power you talked about that you fought
the kid and then the father showed up
yeah you're the fighting the Father tell
us that so how old were you when you're
fighting grown men
[Music]
um
I was like 11 12. that was big you know
I mean I'm like 11 years old by the
month 175 pounds at 11. yeah 160 so so
um
but I'm short though so I'm fighting I
don't know if I'm fighting because I'm
taking them trying to take something for
him that mostly that happens when you're
fighting him and his family so I'm
trying to take some maybe it's jacket or
his watch something I'm trying to take
I'm just I'm trifling like that back
then and then I I would fight with him
and I don't know if I snatched this code
off but his father came running down the
street and when he was on the floor as
far as came and he started to try to
throw I picked him up slammed them on
the floor
and um the kid jumped on me from behind
yeah you know I kicked the ass but they
kicked my ass too you know the
father-son dude they got me good though
they got me good has that ever been uh
uh they got they became my close friends
still how did that happen I don't know
that's what happened you understand you
fight your friends to the death of me
try to Rob them and then as time goes on
you guys become friendly you guys Rob
other people right so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign